the Joe Rogan experience did you hear
about the new electron are age of a cow
tipping that's going on in San Francisco
and stuff like that people are flipping
those little baby electrodes smart card
tipping yeah that's what Wow Matt if you
went outside and you you're a girl and
you weigh a hundred pounds yeah that's a
dick move I also think I so I grew up in
the suburbs I did not see a lot of cows
I guess your time to time but like you
can't even actually typical Columbus
Ohio me and my friends did it twice
you've done it was it like a calf was
veal calves to just me so weak what
happens is that when the cows and the
cows are in the fields they they pretty
much lock their legs and sleep standing
a lot that's how I sleep and so you just
go next time and push them and they just
fall heavy
no they they just tip right over I think
out tipping sighs this was stuff that
suburban kids like or that like urban
lore because none of us ever hung out
with cows yeah you ever want to go
cow-tipping I'll take it they would
really like that yet no they don't I
wouldn't like it yeah believe it yeah me
and to my friends okay and I want to see
one of those where those night vision
like the Paris Hilton videos I wanted to
be one of those night vision videos of
the cow all right do you have an
Instagram I do it's it's my name just at
Alexis Ohanian or Ohanyan
okay that's another thing that's
annoying about these things is that they
insist on trying to change what you
wrote like they're like my creative the
ethnic yeah they're like it's like it
personally it's just that they're their
autocorrect is like really aggressive in
goofy they're awake yeah well then good
luck they're gonna kill you
I see no house to look at these videos
before you put them online bro seriously
find something real you can do that
right yeah you might thought you on
mushrooms tripping balls off to the
tip-cat cows but we never left the house
man what are you talking about we were
in the field you know remember I was
there
I was tipping cows yeah I bet if we
Snopes tipping cows Snopes Snopes cow
tip I feel I should have wrote my laptop
also side note and I've been I've
enjoyed your podcast I love how I love
the real-time with the laptops I wish I
wish every show basically had someone in
real-time just calling out shit here we
go out ready all right let's get this
out of the way cow tipping at least as
popular imagine does not exist drunk men
do not on any regular basis needing the
cow masters and put a hard shoulder - a
cow taking a standing snooze dust
tipping the poor animal over while in
the history of the world there have
surely been a few unlucky cows shoved to
their side by boozed up morons we feel
confident in saying that this happens at
a rate roughly equivalent to the Chicago
Cubs winning the World Series okay this
is no gum gots nope cows cows like sit
down in like on their legs and just sit
there and you can go right up to them
and tip them right over this is from
modern farmer calm well I'm convinced
article on cow tipping I've subscribed
modern farmer for a decade now and I
they have never led me astray YouTube
the largest clearinghouse of human
stupidity the world has ever known
you can watch hours of kids taking the
cinnamon challenge teens jumping off
route to rooftops on the trampolines and
the explosive results of fireworks set
off indoors fails to deliver one single
actual cow tipping video the one
exception is a Russian dashcam video
which shows a semi-truck full of cattle
overturning but that's really
you need to watch your house shaking
themselves off and walking away house
not giving a fuck yeah this is a
spectacular - so this uh this article is
called bullshit on you Brian when I was
younger we would go to these farms in
Plains plain city Ohio and they would
have tons of cows and we would break
into the cows smoke weed and there'd be
cows that would break into the cows no
break into the the fence and there would
be cows that would sit there like on
there like perched up like on their like
legs like it's just sitting there
sleeping we would come over just push
him right over I don't know if that's
the Calla tipping that you heard
everybody doing like people saying that
the cows tip over but that's what we
used to do because that's what we
thought you were supposed to do I don't
understand what you just said this cows
are standing upright because they stand
up when they sleep right no not all the
time there's cows that like like Nathan
okay I thought cows always stood up
horses always stand up right III have no
idea I'm like my guts telling me horses
are the ones your horses I think always
stand up right yeah and if they're down
they're hurt we have the Google yeah but
I'm really scared of this cow tipping
sorry we have brown cows that's how we
roll the cow would be like that and you
just push it yeah but there'd be tons of
cows it'll be night at time when we'll
be drunk and that's what we's well but
exactly that seems to be cow tipping
technically that's cow tipping they're
just lying down cows so you're gonna
send the email to Snopes saying well
actually you're wrong well I am feeling
the problem with calling bullshit if you
didn't grow up in that environment you
might truly believe that it is bullshit
but then when I like Brian actually grew
up there and actually pushed over some
cows we take this to your fan base they
would sit like this and then you just
like set go over there and just push
them over and they would roll over and
wake up and freak out and it would be
scary and you would run away now cow
tipping what I think they're saying is
not true is actually tipping over a cow
it's Ling completely standing out well
maybe that's what people have in their
head but what it really is is what
you're talking about that's when we did
it we just did cuz we heard people did
it and then we were like let's do it
Brian Redman move I heard of the people
are doing it and I'm like well they're
still alive okay
fuck it so then cow tipping is real I
guess I would say oh yeah a cow rolling
I'm gonna call it cal rolling yeah well
then cow tipping as an account standing
up and you pushing it over that doesn't
exist but that's probably not what cow
tipping ever was unless they do sleep
standing up the cows sleep standing up
yeah but do they also sleep standing up
or should I say let me just say how much
I appreciate you guys get into the
bottom of this
we should worst case how far away from
some cows not that far we get to learn
in an hour okay does a cow sleep
standing common misconception that
Kyle's don't lie down mmm
why cows may doze off for a few minutes
at a time while standing up they
typically lie down to sleep or simply to
rest okay
I'm bullshit on the people calling
bullshit I think Brian's right I think
Brian is right he went cow tipping and
that's how you really count him because
what everybody says is that cows are
sleeping and you go up and push them
well obviously if that's not true if
they only take a little nap standing up
and usually they sleep on the bottom
then their whole premise sucks because
they don't understand what cow tipping
is mmm cow tipping starts from the knees
like jujitsu class like if you take
wrestling class you start standing up
for the most part a roomful of 50 dudes
trying to double leg each other that
shit gets really dangerous so jujitsu
classes all start from the knees so real
cow tipping like the idea of it doesn't
exist because that's like wrestling
style
everybody starts from their feet but
jujitsu style when you're already on the
ground
that's real this is great now whenever I
Drive past a bunch of cows will be
thinking about jujitsu that's what I do
that's the vision it's my gift you
should um you should totally that's
enough to go fuck themselves up the
craziest thing is the modern farmer
incorporate or whatever how scary it was
I just remembered is this no because I'd
be scared
we did I remember twice but we only
remembers twice first I'm scared the
fuck out of you and then you like listen
I did it wrong yeah the reason why is
because one of the we used to hang out
this bridge where we would drink an
underage and it was just like everyone
would go to this bridge in the middle of
nowhere and there was all these farms
around it and that's why we'd go there
cuz there was no police or no one could
even know you were there so you got
bonfires and all this shit like that so
then after you got wasted every kind of
move laid around in all the fields in
one of the fields place cows and it was
pitch black because it was in the middle
of the country so it's just stars and
you see shadows of cows and so you would
like sneak up going up to these cows you
didn't have cell phones for lights or
anything like that
so it was literally just lighters and
shit and you just go up and just push it
real fast and it will go and let you
just run away and it was the scariest
shit ever Wow and you'd be stoned
already did you ever find mushrooms on
those cow patties yeah but back then you
just didn't think about that like I
didn't get into mushrooms till I was in
college well Duncan went to school in
Asheville North Carolina and when I went
up there I understand Duncan so much
more after visiting Asheville because
it's just a hippie mecca and they were
getting sand there's apparently the
mushroom flora or whatever it is the
spores are so healthy up there this
because it rains a lot and there's so
many of them that they had to start
giving the cows some sort of an anti
fungal diet to kill the mushrooms
because so many people are harvesting
meanwhile probably makes the kids sick
because a few mushrooms probably grow on
at some poor poisoned psilocybin I mean
you want to talk about missing the
fucking point right poisoning cow shit
so that the most beautiful thing that
God ever created can't grow there you
fucking dummies but he said that they
would constantly go there and just pluck
them off and just eat them they were
everywhere and just trip balls the whole
town is so psychedelic like partially
because of that the whole town is like
it's a Asheville North Carolina is it
trippy fucking place I feel like I need
to visit now you got a visit it's
awesome it's really cool everybody's
walking around like they have a main
area where like bars and restaurants are
and people just walking around like
everybody's walking around it's like a
small town
that exists in a giant world but they're
modern since it's a I fucked up I
shouldn't have told you guys about it
it's gonna row Nashville yeah but I kind
of understand Duncan way more now after
going to this town's like oh I see like
you you were spawned in one of the most
awesome environments on earth like this
place is fucking sweet what what did
they call it when they went out on an
expedition I wonder this you wanna go
Tippin no want to go like candy room
harvesting and some kind of thing that's
so dangerous because I remember even
that's a kid just going up and eating
berries because I was like oh look
berries I Wow you know and then you find
out those kids hundred years ago you
would never survive huh there's no way
you would have been dead before we was
fire yeah fuck it was a honeysuckle shit
like I used to eat a lot of look was
that purple stuff where you pull it out
just suck on it was nothing to do yeah
so we just eat grass yeah I would eat a
few things you know what I found out -
tastes good actually is dandelions like
dandelion greens huh
makes salads at a dandelion greens my
grandmother used to make them and I went
over the house once and she had this
dandelion salad I was like what is that
and so the garden dandelions and they
were like it's really good for you it's
edible - my aunt my uncle tell me it was
good for me I think it's were convinced
me but then I found out that it's like a
common vegetable that a lot of people he
did you make me tea and my already makes
you out of it I believe you can yeah but
it's it's actually good like as a salad
it's a good tasting green and pretty
fucking good for you - hmm what's not to
like I don't know how we got a dandelion
business I know how we got out to the
dead we've covered a lot of Grimm on
this yeah I'm doing free eco friendly
makes the world around my friend